[Musique]
m
monsieur le président bonjour bonjour
peu importe ce qui se passe à l'heure
actuelle quel que soit le thème dont
nous parlons il y a toujours ce fichu
coronavirus quelque part dans le
contexte
oui que pensez vous de la fameuse
deuxième vague donc ont peur tout
d'abord qu'est-ce que la deuxième vague
dans la vie courante on entend parler
d'une deuxième vague
les médias aussi parle d'une deuxième
vague c'est que nous sommes tous devenus
un peu chercheur au cours de ces
derniers mois
la deuxième vague est une expression
toute faite un peu oui c'est vrai mais
en réalité ce qu'il faut voir c'est
l'évolution de la situation
épidémiologique
c'est le terme que les experts suggèrent
d'utiliser en europe on voit une telle
évolution et les chiffres augmentent
panier ça peut tout à fait s'expliquer
c'est une évidence avec la saison
touristique
j'ai eu beaucoup de gens sur les plages
dans les bars prix dans les restaurants
et le manque de discipline tout
simplement
ben oui c'est cet individualisme cette
mentalité qui consiste à ne pas tenir
compte des intérêts de l'ensemble de la
société où est ta bouche pour conduit à
ce que nous voyons dans certains pays
c'est à dire une hausse du nombre de cas
de korn un virus et on voit cette
situation se reproduire mon adultes mais
j'espère quand même que cela n'arrivera
pas et que l'europe comme d'autres
parties du monde va s'en sortir
cali tour de façon générale perçois tu
nous avons beaucoup de malades en russie
non mais nous avons l'un des taux de
mortalité les plus bas au monde
michto et non cela s'explique par le
niveau de préparation de notre système
de santé mais ce dernier on peut se
mobiliser abcès et prendre rapidement
des décisions pour faire face aux
menaces venues aux gosses ya les
chiottes
encore une fois je tiens à faire part de
mon admiration pour le travail de notre
personnel médical très douteux
c'est dans la tradition de l'ensemble
des peuples de russie ou scandant le
peuple russe que les autres mobilisent
au de se mobiliser face à une menace
commune young tiger woods mais c'est
encore ce qui s'est passé c'est facile
je n'ai
c'est aussi grâce à tous les niveaux du
pouvoir tant au niveau fédéral qu'au
niveau local jeunes boulistes qui a su
mobiliser toutes les ressources
nécessaires et se concentrait sur les
solutions pour résoudre ces défis patent
voglans bourgoin le plus important dans
tout cela riz et je lui ai dit à
plusieurs reprises et c'est la vie et la
santé des gens mobilisèrent cette
mobilisation générale
ces mesures ponctuelles qui sonné les
chaînes ils se sont avérés très efficace
non nous ont permis de passer le pic de
l'épidémie
j'espère que nous avons réussi à le
placer et de créer les conditions
nécessaires pour poursuivre ce travail
des déchets et à chaque fois que j'ai la
possibilité de le rappeler publiquement
et bien je le fais tu oublies ch c'est à
travers cet écran que vous communiquez
vous avez une réunion avec le
gouvernement mercredi
quand j'ai la possibilité de parler
publiquement
comme lors de notre dernière
conversation machin pourparlers si je
m'adresse à nos concitoyens pour leur
demander malgré les inconvénients que
cela représente
sauf qu'ils me le garder à l'esprit que
le virus n'a pas disparu ni qu'il faut
continuer à être vigilants et si
possible bien sûr à respecter les
mesures restrictives que les
spécialistes nous incite à respecter
c'est aujourd'hui un disque et plus nous
aurons discipline et maubourguet que
vise nous pourrons revenir à une vie
normale
on mène beaucoup d'études y compris sur
ce que l'on appelle l'immunité
collective ou l'immunité de groupe
il est déjà clair que dans huit régions
de la fédération de russie
cette immunité de groupe a dépassé les
25 % dans l'ensemble cela suggère
guignard nous y allons progressivement
en évitant une trop forte diffusion de
la maladie alors il y aura une
croissance est bien une certaine
résurgence peut-être n'accuse pas les un
moment donné je l'espère on verra une
baisse le déclin est déjà en cours dans
mon jeu nous le savons bien fait alors
que mon sens de les un certain moment la
situation se stabilisera complète de
recourir
cela parce que nous avons suffisamment
de lits d'hôpitaux c'est une bonne
réserve d'équipements de protection
individuelle pas limpide un médicament
pour lutter contre les effets de la
pandémie verte et maintenant comme
chacun sait on a un vaccin
attendez on en parlera plus tard quoi
qu'il en soit nous avons tous les
personal nous en disposons il ces études
sont faites régulièrement sa liste au
japonais spécialistes savent quoi faire
et comment je tombais même pour que la
maladie soit aussi bénigne que possible
sans conséquence grave est intenable
bourg nous allons certainement jeunes
utilisaient toutes ses connaissances
acquises à l'avenir vladimir
vladimirovitch j'ai eu l'autre jour le
sentiment que j'avais changé de lieu de
travail
c'était quand vous avez annoncé la mise
au point de ce vaccin
mais à mi latino américains il se trouve
que j'ai des relations avec cette partie
du monde
on fait travailler comme correspondant
pour les télévision argentine
uruguayenne etc
je ne sais pas je vais me permettre
d'exprimer cette pensée en effet la
plupart d'entre eux ont partagé avec moi
cette idée lorsque vous avez mentionné
que votre fille avaient été vaccinés
avec le nouveau vaccin russe cela les a
beaucoup impressionné je sais à quel
point vous êtes sensible à ces questions
personnelles mais juste après il ya eu
des critiques en particulier venant des
états unis et de l'europe
vous avez d'ailleurs parlé avec le
gouvernement mercredi dans ce même
bureau et vous avait déjà parlé d'un
deuxième vaccin non et qu'est ce qu'on
entend dire à ce sujet qu'est ce que
c'est que ce vaccin il n'a passé que
deux phases d'essais sur les trois
nécessaires qu'ont donc fait ces russes
et en effet il n'y a eu que deux étapes
non mais nous avons fait tout ce qui
était nécessaire pour enregistrer ce
vaccin à une condition comme l'on dirait
tout ce mois dernier chez cette
condition sous-entend une étude plus
approfondie de ce médicament
quand ils seraient utilisés à grande
échelle cela a donc été fait en stricte
conformité avec la loi russe et les lois
russes sont tout à fait conformes les
pratiques internationales et à la
réglementation en vigueur dans d'autres
pays nous avons réalisé des essais
précliniques et cliniques sur des
animaux puis sur des volontaires sains
et il est évident aujourd'hui pour nos
spécialistes que ce vaccin apporte une
immunité stable qui tirera des anticorps
apparaissent et de chez comme ça a été
le cas chez ma fille n'a pu s'ouvrir
le vaccin est anodin et dieu merci je
skie ma fille se portent bien
d'ailleurs vous at elle demandé conseils
ou non c'est une adulte bien sûr elle
est adulte c'est elle qui a pris cette
décision
elle était volontaire ou cela faisait
partie de son travail non oui c'est ça
en tant que volontaire et aussi dans le
cadre de son métier votre vie qui
s'occupe de problématiques médico
biologiques
elle travaille avec un grand nombre de
personnes et de la touche mais bien sûr
cela doit se faire en totale sécurité
j'ai dit qu'elle avait eu 38 4 degrés de
fièvre le premier jour 27 le jour
suivant et c'est tout ebay et après la
deuxième
administration du vaccin 21 jours après
il ya aussi une légère hausse de
température et oser tout va bien je
viens de lui parler au téléphone tu dieu
merci tout va bien
je le répète puisque les études se
poursuivent donc on a su et tout se
passe dans le cadre de la loi russe qui
est tout à fait conforme aux pratiques
internationales
on en société nous aurons un autre
vaccin en septembre
le médicament dont on parle actuellement
a été conçu développé et enregistré par
l'institut gamaleya il s'agit du scout
c'est le spoutnik béton et le deuxième
comme on me l'a dit sera prêt en
septembre manimal en beauté c'est le
célèbre institut victor de novossibirsk
travaille dessus
je suis sûr que les spécialistes de
vector vont mettre au point un très bon
vaccin qui aidera beaucoup de ces deux
médicaments seront ils concurrents ou
complémentaires il faut voir cela avec
les spécialistes
je pense qu'ils seront plutôt
concurrents car en terme de sécurité et
d'efficacité
il ne devrait pas être équivalent badini
cas j'aimerais qu'on parle de la
contraction de l'économie
il ya une semaine et demie des analystes
d'oxford mais aussi l' agence moody's
ces dernières 24 heures ont donné des
chiffres quant à la contraction de
l'économie russe qui en général semble
aller bien par rapport à ce qui se passe
aux etats-unis et c'est regrettable
parce que le reste du monde dépend des
états unis mais si on regarde vraiment
ce qui se passe à quel point cela est
sensible quelles sont les perspectives
de rétablissement
nos anciens l'ensemble de l'économie
mondiale est confrontée aux conséquences
sévères de cette épidémie
rappelons nous des années 2008-2009 de
la crise de l'époque date autre que
louis de la crise financière la baisse
du pib mondial avait été de 0,1 pour
cent seulement cette fois selon les
experts du fmi de la banque mondiale et
d'autres organisations cela va être de
5% environ
autrement dit la différence est énorme
beaucoup compare cela à la grande
dépression des années 1930 aux
événements d'après guerre d'autant plus
que dans les pays qui avaient été
frappés par la dépression des années 30
la chute est aujourd'hui plus
significatives qu'à l'époque non
aux états unis on parle d'une récession
de 9 % et chez nous on prévoit moins
huit et demi pour cent mais nos experts
estiment que cela sera peut-être moins
5% si je ne m'abuse
oui 5 à 6% de contraction environnement
pour les etats unis c'est moins neuf et
demi pour cent au premier semestre une
et -15% pour la zone euro certains
experts nous le savons très bien mais
estime que c'est là le résultat des
différences structurelles de nos
économies cela semble être partiellement
le cas mais c'est essentiellement le
résultat des décisions prises par les
gouvernements
ces mesures ponctuelles et ce qui est
très important à mon avis c'est qu'elles
sont opportunes canyoning
alors bien sûr il y a quelques problèmes
je sais que certaines entreprises ne
sont pas disons sur la liste de celles
bénéficiant du soutien de l'état de tous
alors qu'elles ont vraiment été fauché
sur le gouvernement doit y réfléchir et
prendre les décisions qui conviennent
bon moment mais en général je le répète
pour ce qui est du soutien d'une petite
entreprise il ya certains grands groupes
industriels dans l'agriculture
l'automobile le bâtiment
cela représente des milliers des
millions de personnes car tout est
interdépendant
c'est bien ce soutien a été fait au
moment opportun et à donner des
résultats
regardez nos indicateurs
macroéconomiques clés sont assez stables
malgré les prévisions de fortes
fluctuations
le taux d'inflation aujourd'hui est
d'environ 3,4 points et selon les
prévisions des experts il restera à ce
niveau la norme de 3.4 3,41 pour cent et
le prix du pétrole est de 46 dollars le
baril il vaudrait mieux qu'ils soient un
peu plus élevé oui mais il est quand
même différent des prévisions initiales
oui bien sûr mais nos réserves
augmentent aussi malgré toutes les
difficultés nous réserve augmente ce qui
permet de créer un matelas de sécurité
complémentaires personnalité et c'est
important jeu ce n'est pas un remède
miracle à tous les problèmes mais c'est
important
cela nous permet d'avoir une certaine
conviction que si nécessaire et après
nous pourrons réunir les fonds y compris
pour financer des objectifs sociaux
tout cela montre que tout d'abord nous
estimons avoir déjà dépassé le pic des
problèmes et je l'espère que nous
commencerons petit à petit à nous
redresser
en ce sens il n'y a pas de grande
différence entre nous et les autres pays
du monde
j'estime que l'année prochaine ce
redressement sera acquis oui en effet
que tout le monde soit en bonne santé au
sens propre du terme économique oui bien
sûr monsieur le président les facteurs
économiques ne sont pas les seuls à
avoir une influence sur l'économie comme
le pétrole que nous avons évoqués et qui
malgré les prévisions est à 46 dollars
le baril
il y a également des facteurs politiques
parmi lesquels la biélorussie notamment
oui bien sûr vos conversations
téléphoniques avec les dirigeants
européens ont été de nombreuses fois
rapportée mais généralement ce ne sont
que des messages peu informatifs du
service de presse du kremlin
vous n'avez encore jamais publiquement
parlé en détail de votre vision de la
situation
que pensez-vous des événements en
biélorussie vous savez à mon avis mais
face aux événements en république de
biélorussie lignes trains nous agissons
avec beaucoup plus de retenue et de
neutralité que de nombreux autres pays
européens sud américain
ou même les états unis il me semble que
nous couvrons de manière assez objective
en profondeur si l'on compte les deux
parties les événements qui se déroulent
en biélorussie chattem jeter nous
considérons que c'est avant tout la
sphère de la société biélorusse elle
même nom du peuple biélorusse mais nous
ne sommes certainement pas indifférents
à ce qui se passe là bas c'est un pays
qui nous est très proche peut-être le
plus proche
il vise ou du point de vue ethnique mais
aussi en raison de la langue de la
culture de l'esprit
il y a des dizaines peut être des
centaines de milliers voire des millions
de liens familiaux directes entre nous
la coopération dans le domaine
industriel est très étroite 9 6 voire
bio preuve 90 % des exportations
agricoles biélorusses sont destinés au
marché russe
donc ce que les biélorusses produisent
c'est pour la russie ce qui est destiné
à l'exportation oui et dans d'autres
domaines aussi par exemple dans le
domaine de la construction de machines
agricoles
par conséquent bien su en caniche la
nuit nous ne sommes pas indifférents à
ce qui se passe là-bas après je décide
mais c'est la sphère du peuple qui est
le russie nous partons bien entendu de
l'hypothèse selon laquelle tous les
participants à ce processus
auront suffisamment de bon sens pour
trouver calmement sans verser dans les
extrêmes une solution connue ce n'est
celui bien sûr si les gens descendent
dans la rue
si tout le monde devrait en tenir compte
écoutez réagir et d'ailleurs le
président biélorusse a bien dit qu'il
était prête à envisager la possibilité
de procéder à une réforme
constitutionnelle adopté une nouvelle
constitution à tenir de nouvelles
élections parlementaires présidentielle
sur la base de cette nouvelle constitue
sur nos maisons ne peut sortir du cadre
de la constitution actuelle il ne vous a
pas échappé que la cour
constitutionnelle biélorusse j'avais
décrété que la création d'organes de
supra nancy notionnels un non prévue par
la loi fondamentale du pays et qui
tentait de saisir le ivoire est
absolument inadmissible et il est
difficile de ne pas être d'accord avec
ça j'ai regardé ce qu'on écrivait à
l'étranger sur la biélorussie et souvent
il ne s'agit pas d'idéologie mais de
simples
de nombreux articles étrangers sur les
événements biélorusses sont accompagnés
de renseignement ce qu'est la
biélorussie où elle se trouve
parce que pour beaucoup de gens la
biélorussie est un pays très lointain
mais pas pour les russes et bien sûr en
russie nous nous souvenons non seulement
des événements qui ont eu lieu après les
élections mais aussi de ce qui s'est
passé avant les élections nous nous
souvenons notamment des 33 haute de la
résidence belle rousse ocz cas de ses
citoyens russes qui ont été arrêtés
vadimir vladimirovitch qui est tombé
dans le piège de qui ici non chasse au
tai chi minh
c'est évident il s'agit d'une opération
des services secrets lui dès les
personnes que vous avez mentionné ont
été utilisés sans le savoir
perrine le but était de les envoyer sur
le territoire biélorusse minimes ce que
je leur donnais des objectifs et à fait
légaux comme ims elle devait comme on
leur a dit partir pour des pays tiers en
amérique latine et au moyen-orient pour
un travail absolument légale mais en
réalité on les a fait venir biélorussie
elles ont été présentées comme une force
de frappe prétendument destiné à
déstabiliser la situation pendant la
campagne électorale
je tombe ce thème ce qui n'était
absolument pas le cas ces gens je le
répète
l'udc devait partir travailler dans des
pays tiers il propose mans ils ont été
attirés là bas j'ai transporté de
l'autre côté de la frontière
nos gardes frontières ne les ont pas
laissé passer non mais avec de faux
papiers ils ont effectivement pu être
transportés dans le pays par les
services secrets ukrainiens
c'est une opération conjointe des
services spéciaux ukrainiens et
américains nous savons déjà
certains participants à ce processus où
certains observateurs des gens bien
informés ne le cachent désormais
monsieur le président je crois que j'ai
eu de la chance dans ma carrière de
journaliste car alexandre lukashenko m'a
accordé trois longues interviews mais
vous le connaissez bien mieux que moi
à cet égard je voudrais citer ce
qu'alexandre loukachenko a dit après un
entretien téléphonique avec vous je vous
en prie il a dit que pour se quitter de
la composante militaire il y avait un
accord avec la fédération de russie dans
le cadre du traité d'union et celui
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective
et que ces moments-là été réglé par sous
traitants auparavant il a dit que vous
vous étiez mis d'accord pour aider minsk
à la première demande
mais qu'est ce qu'on entend par ces
moments-là il est inutile d'essayer de
cacher quoi que ce soit
effectivement le traité d'union et le
traité de sécurité collective prévoit
des articles selon lesquels tous les
états membres desdites organisations y
compris du traité d'union et de
comprendre que deux membres la russie et
la biélorussie doivent s'entraider pour
protéger leur souveraineté leurs
frontières extérieures ainsi que leur
stabilité
c'est ce qui est écrit il à cet égard
nous avons bien évidemment certains
engagements envers la biélorussie
alexandre loukachenko a soulevé cette
question
il a exprimé le souhait que le cas
échéant à 15 lignes pour lui apporte une
assistance appropriée ce que moi je peux
rester j'ai répondu que la russie allait
respecter l'ensemble de ses engagements
bush opération alexandre lukashenko m'a
demandé de constituer une certaine
réserve de forces de l'ordre et je les
fais ya été au nombre des gaullistes
mais nous avons aussi convenu goût
douteux ce point que je ne l'utiliserai
pas à moins que la situation ne soit
hors de contrôle
cada x king's queer prête je n'ai que
des éléments je le souligne extrémistes
pas quoi mais franchise certaines
limites politiques team aux mini pc
lance dans le banditisme pour qu'ils
mettent par exemple le feu à des
voitures par mois des maisons à des
banques ou qu'ils tentent d'occuper des
bâtiments administratifs
nguyen au cours de notre conversation
avec alexandre lukashenko autant que
nous avons conclu que pour le moment ce
n'était pas nécessaire d'allier et
j'espère que ce ne sera pas nécessaire
c'est pour cela que l'on n'utilise pas
cette réserve pour tailler schueren je
le répète à gauche toute nous partons du
principe que l'ensemble des problèmes
qui existent aujourd'hui en biélorussie
nocturnes seront réglés pacifiquement
beauté ni bobo et que s'il ya des
violations
de la part de qui que ce soit ait encore
des organes d'état des forces de l'ordre
à des manifestants
yes les niveaux qu'ils enfreignent la
législation en vigueur
il y aura une réponse appropriée au
regard de la loi
la loi doit être la même pour tous au
nom et pour être équitable investir
estime que malgré tout on les forces de
l'ordre biélorusses la jce avec
modération de chongqing nice matin
regardez ce qui se passe dans d'autres
pays chauds newcastle malgré deux
premiers jours beaucoup étaient mal à
l'aise a heureusement vous savez ce que
je pense à ce sujet est-ce qu'on était
si mal à l'aise quand dans certains pays
européens des gens mouraient presque
tous les jours c'est pour ça que
loukachenko a refusé la médiation des
manuels maquereau en offrons en retour
son aide avec les gilet jaune
c'est ce qu'on est pas mal à l'aise
comme d'un but bizarre quand on tire
dans le dos d'une personne désarmée
devant ses trois enfants qui se trouvent
dans la voiture c'est terrifiant c'est
terrifiant non 13 oct autant il se tire
pas ceux qui accusent aujourd'hui le
président non les autorités biélorusses
que chaque place venir dénonce-t-il ces
actes lâches tout ni je n'ai rien vu de
ce genre en vidéo tu goûtes à 15
pourquoi ont-ils cette approche
sélective
cela m'amène à penser que ce n'est pas
la question de ce qui se passe en
biélorussie
quelqu'un veut que quelque chose d'autre
cybardeaux guen veut influer sur ses
processus était par access et parvenir à
des décisions qui correspondent aux
intérêts politiques de ses genoux
mouloud et c'est pourquoi je le répète
un temps d'une façon générale la
situation se stabilise et j'espère que
tous les problèmes il y en a de toute
évidence des problèmes sinon les gens ne
sortirait pas dans la rue c'est certain
que tous les problèmes seront réglés
conformément à la constitution dans le
respect des lois
c'est par des moyens pacifiques monsieur
le président merci
[Musique]